je reçois le premier ministre du canada
justin trudeau en studio bonjour je suis
très doux bonjour alors ce matin dans
les journaux un peu partout on apprend
que votre gouvernement va annoncer
aujourd'hui un plan visant à interdire
peut-être dû 1021 les articles en
plastique à usage unique comme n'est pas
exclue exact d'une part cette
information oui on va faire une grosse
annonce aujourd'hui qui est en train de
suivre dans ce qu'on fait depuis
plusieurs années on a éliminé les
microbilles à partir du 1er juillet 2018
pour en finir ce 1er juillet si lors de
notre g7 à charlevoix on a développé une
approche internationale sur lequel veut
plus que vingt différents pays on se
sont embarqués et nous maintenant on va
on va annoncer notre notre approche qui
va reconnaître que les problèmes de
pollution par des plastiques c'est une
vraie en jeu puis il va falloir qu'on
s'y attarde aller plus haut et clips
aegis aval on va regarder dans la
prochaine année les différentes façons
de faire les items qui va falloir qu'on
élimine ça va être une approche où on va
consulter mais on veut le faire en 2026
a donc vous voulez vous présenter que
comme le gouvernement de l'environnement
en même temps on peut pas faire
autrement plus une manifestation à
vancouver contre les pipelines le fameux
pipeline trans manten dans l'ouest
canadien
donc on peut pas faire autrement que de
se poser des questions sur la
crédibilité environnementale de votre
votre gouvernement c'est comme si vous
parliez des deux côtés de la bouche
au contraire ce qu'on reconnaisse et
qu'il faut absolument agir sur
l'environnement pour protéger en
vraiment et on est en train de le faire
mais il faut quand même reconnaître que
on est encore une société qui est qui a
besoin du pétrole on a besoin de décence
dans nos voitures
on a des ressources pétrolières au
canada mais comme on a vu
malheureusement il ya de plus en plus de
pétrole transporté par trait on le sait
que c'est un beau projet apprend
aujourd'hui le double de la paire avec
celle ci pourrait on sait que des
oléoducs bief est bien gérée
avec un système en place pour répondre
aux accidents est possible un site une
meilleure façon de faire que de se fier
sur des rails mais de là à acheter comme
canadien pipeline long on est dans un
autre domaine complètement pas vraiment
parce qu'on reconnaît que le canada
était prisonnier du marché américain
pour l'exportation de notre pétrole
ils nous donnaient un rabais
épouvantable on avait en perdre
énormément d'argent
on a besoin d'accéder à la au nouveau
marché
orc que les états unis et c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait avec et c'est
pas un c'est un nouveau pipeline mais
c'est le c2c de doubler un pipeline qui
existe depuis depuis 60 ans donc
vraiment que se présentait toujours plus
vert parler beaucoup dans vos projets
d'infrastructure et compagnie franche
rupture au québec
quoique aujourd'hui risque encore
d'avoir une annonce provinciale fédérale
sur la construction d'une route
on parle d'une route l'a35 vers les
états unis est ce que c'est vrai de ne
pas cette information on continue
d'investir dans les infrastructures
nécessaires pour aurore pour la province
je veux pas devant celle annonce qu'on
va faire plus tard donc une route
pendant ce temps là je sais que vous
avez investi dans le rem par un prêt ou
de 2 milliards mais on attend une
annonce officielle toujours de la
fameuse ligne bleue c'est ça sent l'été
creed en ciel mais tant mieux sinon tant
depuis le temps qu'on en parle
le tramway à québec donc il ya beaucoup
de projets mais s'il n'y a pas de deux
pelletées de terre ça va arriver au
contraire on est belle très avancés avec
de grands projets comme on a dit on est
en train de faire livrer sur les projets
oui plusieurs projets qui restent à
venir
on est très excités par le tramway à
québec ce sont là avec les
investissements faut s'accorder avec
avec québec malheureusement le
gouvernement provincial n'est pas aussi
enthousiaste que nous dans les projets
d'infrastructure nous faut qu'on
respecte la province mais on encourage
de livrer sur ses engagements qu'on a
tous fait un enfant vous dites que le
gamer un ciel n'est pas aussi
enthousiaste tout dire on note des fois
d'aidé
fille arriver à faire des annonces
arriver à faire des partenariats mais on
continue de travailler
d'accord parlons un peu d'économie
déficit pour l'an prochain on prévoit
près de 20 milliards c'est 19 milliards
jetés par erreur pour l'an prochain
gouvernement fédéral
la proportion de la dette par rapport au
pib du canada est parmi les plus bas du
g7
on est on est extrêmement santé de façon
fiscale et on a choisi d'investir plutôt
que d'être obsédé par l'austérité et la
dette comme les conservateurs vrai mais
ça fait quand même très de 20 milliards
pour l'an prochain
ce qu'on voyait dans vos documents
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
2040 comme sont plus marcher à ses
passions le document c'est une et on est
en train de réduire la taille du déficit
à chaque année on est en train de
réduire la proportion de la dette comme
comme proportion notre pib
et c'est un record les plus bas on est
dans une situation durable
ce que les gens veulent ce que les
conservateurs veulent s'ils veulent
faire des coupures pour accélérer
l'équipe budgétaire mais ils vont couper
des services pour ça nous aussi que les
investissements en infrastructures les
investissements dans la classe moyenne a
pour sortir les gens de la pauvreté pour
créer des emplois
c'est ça qui livre notre croissance et
on va continuer notre approche qui crée
une économie qui est qui est en train de
très bien fonctionné mais même si en
terme de comparaison en termes de
proportion par rapport au pib
donc vous dites que ça diminue c'est
quand même des déficits qui s'accumulent
on sort d'un cycle économique très
positif depuis 2008 et tous les
économistes le disent ça va finir par
finir normalement les gens qui
normalement dans les gens là leurs
finances qu'ils font c'est que dans des
périodes économiques positives il se met
un coussin il a c'est de payer leurs
dettes parce qu'ils savent que
l'économie ils savent que ça va aller
mal m'emmener est ce que ce serait pas
plus prudent justement de réduire vos
déficits en prévision des gens toujours
plus est une très très bonne question
et ça ça ça vient
perspectives de base les conservateurs
et 10 économies ce traditionnel ils
veulent qu'on accumule une pile d'argent
pour qu'on puisse dépenser quand on a
des mauvais temps moi ce que je
préférais moins du monde est ce que vous
dites moi ce que je préfère ça faire
c'est d'investir dans les emplois
investir dans la formation investir dans
les canadiens investir dans des
infrastructures pour que oui il ya des
moments plus difficiles qui s'en
viennent les gens vont être en train de
travailler vont avoir des bonnes
opportunités et en investissant dans les
gens plutôt que dans un compte de banque
théoriques ont fait beaucoup mieux pour
créer de la résilience village en
économie il est d'être un jour tout le
monde le sait qu'on doit payer tout à
fait mais si on regarde les agences qui
valut le approche fiscale un
gouvernement
moody's snpi à l'international sont en
train de dire que le canada est dans une
situation superbe on a une cote triple à
les gens ont énormément confiance dans
notre approche fiscale d'accord l'année
de votre gouvernement était ainsi ce
qu'on peut dire avec la sphère mode
snc lavalin d'une part est ce que le
grand fédéral à l'intention de mettre en
oeuvre de ce processus de réparation
c'est une entreprise très importante au
québec snc lavalin passionnant au québec
au canada et des milliers d'emplois qui
ont déballé qui en dépendent de ne pas
avez vous l'intention ici oui pourquoi
attendre on est entré comme on l'est
depuis longtemps en train de regarder
les différentes options
on sait que c'est important de défendre
des entreprises défendre les emplois des
canadiens et pas je suis au québec mais
à travers le pays pour pour lavalin par
exemple mais il faut le faire de la
bonne façon vous respecter la règle de
droit et c'est ce qu'on a toujours fait
et c'est ce qu'on va continuer de faire
qu'est ce que voulait dire aig ne doit
pas ce que de droit vous pourriez le
faire maintenant si vous vous dit on est
en train de regarder la bonne approche
pour le faire on respecte le processus
qui se passe devant devant la cour
pendant ce temps là l'entreprise est
très fragilisée on le voit en bourse ce
que je comprends mais est ce que vous
aviez souligner c'est que nous pendant
dans longtemps on a cherché à défendre
ces emplois là il ya des gens qui sont
en désaccord les conservateurs nous
attaquent constamment parce qu'on a
voulu défendre la valeur nous on va
continuer de regarder la mer façon de
faire ça pour que l'on puisse avoir des
emplois au canada qu'on protège les
compagnies qui mérite d'être protégée
mais conviviaux aussi des conséquences
pour des compagnies qui se sont
comportés comporter de façon à
enfreindre la loi
d'accord autre dossier qui se fait
attendre la crise la crise des médias
je sais que dans de vieux gréements
fédéral il ya de l'argent qui est prévu
notamment produit pour les journaux
imprimés écrit mais il reste ya eu des
coupures de postes récemment à tva
un peu partout on le voit dans les
journaux c'était extrêmement fragile il
damas tout ça ça nous permet de ré
abordé le dossier netflix ya de l'argent
aller chercher dans ses tacles je sais
que vous allez me dire vous ne voulez
pas proposer de nouvelles taxes que nous
aimons pas de nouvelles taxes on parle
de nouvelles entreprises qui devraient
normalement être taxés comme les autres
entreprises canadiennes
avez vous l'intention de taxer ni les
autres gaffes d'un sujet à l'autre
d'abord la situation fragilisée des
médias subo directement relié net
l'excellent pour les médias on est très
préoccupé par ce qu'on voit parce que la
lune médias fortes indépendantes réussi
est essentielle à avoir une démocratie
en santé donc pour nous de regarder
comment on va pouvoir appuyer les
journalistes appuie les salles d'une
nouvelle de façon indépendante
c'est très important parce qu'on
reconnaît que la transformation
numérique de notre de notre société amen
des conséquences et des défis importants
pour un dépit de nos démocraties pour ça
qu on est toujours là pour défendre nos
médias et on va continuer de l'être par
rapport aux entreprises globales comme
netflix comme airbnb comme comme toutes
sortes d'entreprises comme ceux qui la
faa gaffe action énormément on est en
train de travailler avec nos partenaires
à l'international pour voir comment on
va pouvoir
à créer un système où tout le monde perd
à sa juste part d'impôt tout le monde
sera sur pied d'égalité que ce soit une
compagnie internationale nous comptons
compagnie domestique
il ya plusieurs réponses qui ont été
proposées par différents pays on est en
train de regarder on va en avoir plus à
dire dans les mois à dire j'en suis dans
les mois à venir j'en suis sûr est ce à
dire que vous revenez sur votre
politique justement de ne pas taxer des
voeux ne fermait pas la porte se serait
pas on n'augmentera pas les impôts
il est temps au noble nom entre apple et
tax sur les contribuables qui payent
leur paye déjà trop cher leurs internet
on va pas augmenter les impôts n'auront
plus elles sont les abaisser de lui même
fort on n'augmente pas les taxes gens
des taxes
aujourd'hui encore combien ils vont y
payer pour leur cellulaire pour le
royaume pour l'heure internet vous leur
demanderez s'ils veulent payer plus cher
pour l'heure un terme et en même temps
les entreprises canadiennes qui elle des
entreprises de télécommunications qui
elles doivent axer les amateurs donc une
question d'équité ou si c'est pour ça
qu'on est en train de regarder un
système mais ce sera pas les
contribuables qui vont payer encore un
dossier très important au québec encore
dont le poids dans le jeu nous jouons ce
matin l'aide médicale à mourir
vous savez que le groupe est en train de
réviser sa politique d' élargir les
critères de l'aide médicale à mourir
pour par exemple accepter des cas comme
les gens qui sont atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer des sondages qui ont été
publiés la semaine dernière qui démontre
un appui que des québécois très
important sur l'élargissement de la
demie ce cas-là mourir il ya des gens
qui prétendent que le québec ne peut pas
le faire sans l'appui du vent fédéral
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
dites on savait quand on a pris cette
décision difficile mais importante de
permettre l'aide médicale à mourir que
c'était quelque chose qui allait évoluer
il faut toujours regarder comment on est
entre est de permettre aux gens
d'assumer la liberté d'avoir leur libre
choix d'avoir leurs droits défendu en
même temps qu'on protège les gens les
plus vulnérables cet équilibre là c'est
au coeur de comment on va avancer et
comment on a choisi d'avancer mais on
savait que il
la avoir d'autres évolutions quand la
société vivait un petit peu avec cette
nouvelle politique cette nouvelle
capacité d'avoir de l'aide médicale à
mourir on savait qu'ils abordent à avoir
des cas qui questionnait est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on a trouvé exactement la
bonne façon de le faire est on est on
est ouvert à toute évolution de façon
responsable les conversations qui s'en
viennent parce que vous même vous êtes
sensibles au corps par exemple des
familles qui vivent une situation très
très pénibles avec extrêmement sensible
et c'est pour ça que dans nos
consultations et sont revenus plusieurs
éléments qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des
des jeunes qui veulent l'aide médicale à
mourir qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des des
gens qui décident bien à l'avant ce que
si ceux ci arrivent ils voudraient avoir
l'aide médicale à mourir même s'ils sont
pas dans une situation de pouvoir donner
leur consentement cdc des questions
délicates essentiel importante très dur
pour les familles les individus et c'est
en société en conversation en essayant
d'évoluer de la bonne façon qu'on voit
qu'on va tranquillement s'adresser à ça
la semaine dernière lors du dépôt du
rapport sur les femmes et filles
assassinées autochtone vous avez fait
sien l'utilisation votre plutôt
l'utilisation du mot génocide qui était
la principale conclusion de ce rapport
or le général dallaire a déclaré je le
cite
gardons-nous d'utiliser ce mot a tort et
à travers ce nom il se videra de tout
son sens et de l'horreur qu'il
représente ce qu'on vient général d'al
haq a quand même vécu une situation
extrêmement dramatique
qu'est ce que vous répondez ou général
j'ai eu la chance de le voir quand on
était en france pour le 75e du
débarquement du jour j et on a eu une
brève conversation là dessus je comprend
quel point c'est un mot est difficile
estime le chargé de 206 d'implication on
avait demandé à des experts de ridge un
rapport sur les femmes et filles perdues
assassines
assassinées et disparues les
commissaires ont remis leur rapport on
accepte leur rapport pour nous a appris
le mot génocide pour moi je me replie
sur la limo utilisé dans la commission
de la vérité réconciliation il ya
quelques années où ils ont parlé de
génocide culturel et je pense que ça a
été très très bien défini mais comme
j'ai dit j'accepte que les commissaires
ont émis leurs rapports j'accepte leur
rapport y compris qu'ils aient utilisé
le mot génocide
mais pour moi il s'est un peu plus
approprié je pense de parler de génocide
culturel donc tandis que justin trudeau
est favorable à l'occasion du moussem 7
vous faites une nuance
oui et je pense que avec le mot génocide
il faut faire des nuances je pense que
le travail qui a été fait dans dans la
commission vérité et réconciliation qui
parle de génocide culturel
je pense que ça a été très bien fait et
pour moi ces logements retrouvent dans
la question
donc on s'en va en campagne électorale
on lui peut-être déjà parce
qu'aujourd'hui par ailleurs y'a pas mal
d'annoncés qui vont être faites
pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous ayez aux
gens qui disent que vous ne méritez pas
deuxième mandat avec s'est passé ou à
sonnerie board
tout dossier environnemental du si
pourquoi vous redonner un deuxième
mandat
je pense que les promesses qu'on a fait
des engagements qu on appris auprès des
canadiens il ya quatre ans c'était de
créer de la croissance qui allait aider
à la classe moyenne
créer créer une économie en santé pour
tout le monde
or on a vu la diminution du taux de
chômage à des records les plus beaux que
j'en comprends mais on a aussi vu 825000
personnes sorties de la pauvreté au
canada et ça c'est en lien direct avec
nos politiques de d'allocations
canadienne aux enfants des deux aînés
d'investissement dans les
dans les sans abri dans les logements
alors on a vu des conséquences directes
de ce qu'on a pu faire d'autre part on a
mis un prix sur la pollution on est en
train de reprendre la place de leader du
canada à l'échelle mondiale sur
l'environnement
on est en train d'avancer pour protéger
les droits des gens on est entraînés sur
dans les infrastructures on est en train
de faire une transformation de la façon
que le canada s'engage avec les peuples
un peuple autochtone
on est on a beaucoup fait mais oui
absolument je suis d'accord avec les
gens qui disent il nous reste du travail
à faire il nous reste d'autres choses à
faire et ce qu'on veut pas c'est un
recul vers leur part parce que c'est
exactement ce que monsieur scheer promet
de revenir comment les choses étaient
sous monsieur harper mais excusez moi on
a fait énormément de progrès depuis
quatre ans il faut le continuer faut pas
aller un pas en arrière
justin trudeau premier ministre du
canada bonne campagne est ce qu'on peut
dire que ça commence là où à peu près ça
va commencer de façon officielle au mois
de septembre mais c'est sûr que les gens
se positionner on parle du bon travail
qu'on est en train de faire le tour du
web